see that's what i'm talking about you go
on a lake and you can get a brain eating
amoeba yeah man with the lakes
isn't there stuff that can go like up
your pee hole oh yeah in the lake hell
yeah dude because when i was in we
filmed an episode in new orleans and uh
i was in the bayou and i was so nervous
about alligators but about amoebas and
[ __ ] and that i i wore a condom through
the whole thing
yeah and then uh so that's a remote
control alligator and they they i didn't
know that that was they had that and i
literally had a did you see me run i
thought an alligator was coming at me
and when i ran to the boat joe thought
that i was wearing a helmet and he took
that ore and he slapped me in the head
with it and there was nothing but my
soft cranium underneath and he hit me
and my literally my eyes went to
blackout i almost went to blackout and i
almost fell back and underneath the
water
like oh my god i'm so sorry dude i was
like ah i was like that [ __ ] hurt he
goes i do you wearing a helmet i go no
he goes oh my god i'm so sorry